This week on Wheel of Science,
we're talking asteroids, right, Neil?
You ain't talking about my asteroid, for sure.
This is Wheel of Science.
(exciting music)
Hey everybody, welcome to Wheel of Science.
The interactive show where we answer your questions
about the universe,
and by we, I certainly don't mean me.
We have with us,
the one, the only,
your own personal astrophysicist,
Doctor Neil deGrasse Tyson.
What's up, Neil?
Church, how you doing?
Thanks for asking man, I'm great.
Where are you beaming in from?
From Vancouver, British Columbia.
And for geographically challenged Americans,
that's Canada, filming the last few days of Cosmos.
God, you are all over the place, man.
Would love to be you right now.
Let's not get into your fantasies.
Okay, all right, it's time to talk asteroids.
Are you ready, Neil?
I'm ready, Chick, spin that wheel.
Daniel Tickner wants to know,
"What is the easiest way
"to defend the earth from asteroids?"
I didn't even know they were trying to attack us.
What you wanna do is first find out
that it's headed our way.
Then as early as you possibly can,
slowly deflect it out of harms way.
Because if the earlier you get it,
you don't have the deflect it by very much,
and that angle accumulates,
and gets wider and wider and wider,
so that it completely misses earth.
The later you do this,
the more significant you have to deflect it so
that it does not hit earth.
And if it's headed right at us,
you have to deflect it the entire diameter of the earth,
just to avoid collision.
So the earlier the better in all cases.
So how would you do that?
Well, one way is you can like paint one side
of the asteroid jet black,
and that'll absorb more sunlight than the other side,
and when that happens,
it radiates at a different rate from one side to the other,
and that difference in radiation rates
has a pressure that pushes it into a new orbit.
But there's still issues at how much spray paint
do you need for this?
What would you actually take out there
to accomplish this?
And these asteroids are large.
The ones we're worried about are miles across, okay.
And if your European, kilometers across.
But that's a lot of spray paint,
so what, is there another way to do it?
Yes, you can send a space ship out there,
and have a space probe
and park it near the asteroid.
So here's the asteroid and here is the space probe.
Just park it there.
Now what's gonna happen is,
the gravity's gonna wanna attract to one another,
but you don't let that happen.
You fire little retro rockets.
So that pulls the, the, the space ship a little farther way,
and then the asteroid falls towards it.
And it's very steady,
but it is in effect,
a gravitational tractor beam.
It's like a gravitational tether.
And that way you can measure how effective it is,
and how long you should do it,
and so that's clearly the best way
to protect earth from asteroids.
So blowing it up Armageddon style,
that's not a good choice?
No, in America, especially,
we're really good at blowing stuff up,
but we're not as good at knowing where
the pieces will land,
so you don't know what effet exploding it will have
after you've blown it up.
So what you're saying Neil,
is Bruce Willis is a fraud.
No, no, the way I put it is,
if we are gonna blow it up for whatever reason,
I'd send Bruce Willis.
All right, Neil, it's time for another question,
are you ready?
Spin the wheel.
Mathew Vincent Liberto wants to know this,
"When considering the asteroid belt,
"where did all the asteroids come from?
"I'm genuinely curious,
"also, if there were an asteroid headed towards earth,
"how would it be made known to the public?"
Okay, Neil, so where did the asteroids come from?
Well, first let me say where they are.
Most of them are between the orbit of Mars and Jupiter.
Hundreds of thousands of them,
and they're craggy chunks of rock left over
from the formation of the solar system.
And we think many of them try to become planets,
like planetesimals, and that,
and the solar system back then
was basically a shooting gallery.
And as they're trying to become planets they get broken up
into bits and pieces.
So they're really the vagabonds of the solar system.
So, what you're saying is it's space garbage, like Pluto?
Chuck, don't get me started.
Okay, I'm joking, I'm joking, okay,
how about the second half of Matt's question?
How are we gonna know that we're all gonna die?
Well, all the movies always show governments detecting
the asteroid with some special telescopes,
and then keeping it a secret.
Excuse me, you can not keep the sky a secret.
It is above all our heads.
And there are countless thousands of amateur astronomers
with backyard telescopes
that look into the universe and find these things.
And so, you realize that most comets,
up until recently most comets
were found by amateur astronomers,
and asteroids, too.
So now we have specialized telescopes
but they're controlled by us,
not by the government.
So, yeah, if we find one,
you're gonna know the next day.
The next day, 'cause that stuff will go public.
And then everybody will find out at the same time,
very likely by the internet.
And it is no secret anybody can keep.
Sorry, Neil, I don't believe you.
I got a feeling they're not telling anybody anything,
Until next time,
and then they're gonna take that information
this is Chuck Nice,
and escape on their own.
from Wheel of Science saying,
keep that asteroid.
Or maybe that's just what I would do,
I'm an awful person.
Which makes me wonder,
if we were gonna get hit by an asteroid,
would you wanna know?
Vote in the poll on the screen right now,
and see what everybody else thinks.
Hey, man, thanks for being here.
As always, it's my pleasure.
Until next time,
this is Chuck Nice from Wheel of Science saying
Keep that asteroid!